نعم بالفعل في هذه الاثناء لا تزال
العمليه العسكريه لجيش الاحتلال متواصله
في مخيم نور شمس الى الشرق من المدينه وسط
اشتباكات مسلحه لا تزال بين الفينه
والاخرى في عده انحاء من المخيم وعبر
مصادرنا داخل المخيم هناك حديث عن انفجار
لعبوه ناسفه
بجرافك فتح احدى احد الطرق في حي المنشيه
الى الشرق من المخيم الاشتباكات حتى هذه
اللحظه لا تزال متواصله والعمليه العسكريه
لجيش الاحتلال متواصله هناك حصار لكافه
مداخل المخيم من الجهه الشرقيه وايضا من
الجهه الغربيه وتحديدا من منطقه ذنابه
وجبل النصر الى جنوب من المخيم حيث
العمليه العسكريه متواصله والاشتباكات
المسلحه لا تزال حت حتى هذه اللحظه اليات
او ما يزيد عن 40 اليه عسكريه اقتحمت
المدينه من عده محاور من منطقه حاجز 104
وما يسمى بتسن عوز الى الغرب من المدينه
وايضا من المنطقه وحاجز عناب الى المنطقه
الشرقيه حيث وصلت هذه التعزيزات العسكريه
الى الشارع الرئيس ما بين مدينه طول كرم
ومدينه نابلس عند احد ابواب او الباب
الرئيسي لمخيم نور شمس وسط اشتباكات مسلحه
وانفجارات لعشرات العبوات الناسفه في ال
المخيم والتي لا تزال حتى هذه اللحظه
عشرات الاليات العسكريه التي في هذه
الاثناء تتواجد على بوابه تساني عوز او
104 الى الغرب من المدينه على ما يبدو ان
الاقتحام لا يزال متواصل وان التعزيزات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في طريقها الى
المخيم من عده محاور والاحتلال في هذه
الاثناء يقوم بعمليه فتح الطريق لعدد من
المداخل يعني للبدء بعمليه الاقتحام
وتدمير البنى التحتيه في هذا الاقتحام
هناك جرافتين دي ناين والمعروفه بقوتها
التدميريه الهائله اقتحمت المخيم والبدء
باعمال الحفر على بعض الطرق في مداخل
المخيم ل تدمير البنى التحتيه من شبكات
الصرف الصحي شبكات المياه ايضا الكهرباء
بالتزامن مع هذا الاقتحام لمدينه طولكرم
هناك اقتحام ل عده مدن وقرى وبلدات في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله منها نابلس حيث
شهدت اشتباكات مسلحه اثناء اقتحام منطقه
او المنطقه الشرقيه من المدينه وايضا في
بعض المناطق في جنوب الضفه الغربيه
المحتله على صعيد مدينه طول كرم ساعه ونصف
الساعه على بدء العمليه العسكريه ولا تزال
التعزيزات العسكريه تصل تباعا حتى هذه
اللحظه يعني الاحتلال يحاصر المخيم منع
تحرك المواطنين هناك اعتداء ورصد لحالات
اعتداء على منازل المواطنين ومركباتهم
المتواجده في
الطرقات الواصله الى مخيم نور شمس حيث
قامت الجرافات بتدمير هذه
ال مركبات وايضا تدمير بعض الاسوار او
اسوار المنازل اثناء مرور الاحتلال
التمركز في هذه اللحظات لا يزال متواصل
لجيش الاحتلال تحديدا في حي المنشيه حيث
هناك عشرات الاليات العسكريه التي تحاصر
هذا الحي الاشتباكات المسلحه في هذا الحي
تحديدا يعني في كل اقتحام يذكر ان
الاقتحام السابق قبل حوالي اسبوع من الان
حيث قام الاحتلال بتدمير كافه او معظم
البنى التحتيه في المخيم